willkommen bei fast einer neuen folge
hallo york heute ist geht es um
kommunikation social media ändert sich
da eigentlich was ich gebe ein paar
beispiele heutzutage wenn wir
smartphones haben ist die kommunikation
ja auch so eine art dass ich mit ihr
schreiben könnte zum beispiel wie geht
es dir was tust du warst du grad und
antwortest du wir haben die freiheit
direkt leute jederzeit an zu schreiben
was uns aber auch möglich ist es
jederzeit unterhaltungen zu verlassen
ich kann einfach weggehen und jetzt bei
der frage nach der neuartigkeit frage
ich mich nämlich das wäre ja ganz
komisch wenn im reallife wir reden jetzt
miteinander wenn ich jetzt einfach
aufstehen geht so und das bleibt so das
ist irgendwie komisch
deswegen ist ja meine frage gibt es eine
neuartigkeit ist die und und ist diese
also eine andersartigkeit will ich mich
bezweifelt aber es ist wirklich eine
neue einheit mehr gute frage die
natürlich jetzt auch verweist auf die
frage nach der ethik der kommunikation
so sagt das schon vorhin gerade wenn du
jetzt einfach aufstehen würdest und
gehen würdest dann wäre das eine
unhöflichkeit mir gegenüber und ich
denke man sieht den internetnutzern
manche verhaltensweisen ihr nach zb sich
aus einem chat zu entfernen ohne sich zu
verabschieden
und ich glaube dass eben durch die
andere raum und zeit logik die im
internet herrscht und diesen ganzen chat
medien auch eine andere art von
verhaltensweise in der kommunikation
entsteht wo man manche dinge dem anderen
nutzer ihr nach sieht ja wo man aber
auch andere dinge dem der nutzerin vogel
ja es bleibt nämlich archiviert man kann
zum beispiel dinge die gesagt wurden
nicht mehr so leicht revidiert genau zb
man muss auch schauen welche form von
kommunikation findet über das internet
statt
wir hatten ja schon mal darüber geredet
dass es ganz verschiedene formen von
kommunikation gibt verbal para verbal
und nonverbal das heißt die ganze
körperlichkeit
die bei einer kommunikation eine große
rolle spielt auch die tonhöhe oder der
augenkontakt usw
der feldweg bei der
internetkommunikation ausgeglichen wird
diese para oder nonverbale kommunikation
durch smileys oder durch grafische
symbole die man ganz dezent kontrolliert
einsetzen kann
aber das fängt natürlich nur eine
dimension unserer sehr reichhaltigen
alltäglichen kommunikation also mir
scheint dass dieses das gesagte bleibt
und das ungesagte tritt nicht so in den
fokus
genau das nun oder para verbal auch
kommuniziert findet kein weg ins
internet
es bleibt eigentlich nur das wort hat
den die proposition ahlen struktur an
netzwerk und daher ist es eben auch
nicht so unhöflich eine diskussion zu
verlagern weil eben das paar verbale
keine rolle mehr
das heißt es kommt auch eine viel
größere unverbindlichkeit ins spiel
alles ist im kommen und gehen wir sind
nicht physikalisch anwesend wir schauen
uns nicht ins gesicht ja alles wird auch
ein bisschen unverbindliche und hier
wäre der punkt eben auch eine ethik der
digitalen kommunikation oder einen
etikett oder sowas zu fordern also
gelungener chat austauschen internet
musste aussehen ok ja hast du da
vorschläge dafür ein 2 zentrale aussagen
zum beispiel so was ja mal jemanden
ausreden lassen soll häufig so was
könnte man auch dort einfügen
ich meine das ausreden lassen ist nicht
das problem weil jemand der einsatz
beendet mit einem punkt und dann
erdrückt geben dann kommen die
sprechblase bis dahin gibt es ja keine
keine interferenz auch durch den anderen
kommt dass jeder damit vielleicht eher
gelöst dieses problem anderes problem
wäre vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
eine intensivere diskussion das problem
von chats ist häufig dass man auch ein
bisschen ab trifft dass man sich nicht
so konzentrieren kann
also hier wäre glaube ich eine ganz
klare struktur sinnvoll
vielleicht auch eine konzentration auf
bestimmte zeichenanzahl so wie wir das
bei twitter haben dass man nicht zu
langatmig wird wie ich jetzt tue zu
wenig
also konzentration aufs wesentliche
fakten die in der kürze liegt die würze
ich zeige ich glaube das ist so eine
möglichkeit wo die internet
kommunikation besser werden kann
das heißt es wird sich wahrscheinlich
tut es ja eh schon ein wandel in der
sprache vollziehen hat es aber auch eine
auswirkungen und wenn ja welche
auswirkungen auf unsere wahrnehmung der
welt wenn alles irgendwie kürzer ist
mehr auf den punkt gebracht hast ja als
ich die gefahr besteht darin dass wir
die welt reduzieren wenn wir uns auf die
kürze konzentrieren können wir nicht mit
den reichtum der sprache einbringen und
das note gefahr dass wir die welt nur
verkürzt wieder geben
eine andere chance besteht darin die
welt kommentiert wiederzugeben
also die welt irgendwie im wesen zu
fassen und nicht nur drum herum zu reden
um den heißen brei
das ist eine chance und gefahr zugleich
ok danke york zum thema kommunikation
haben wir noch ein ähnliches video und
zwar über mimikry von der mall of
psychology workshop sessions und dies
dann auch im description verlinkt sonst
bis zu einer nächsten folge und bis dann